[Musique]
nous sommes dans le laboratoire du corps
le colas ricerche center avec myriam des
rushes bonjour
[Musique]
c'est quoi le quotidien ici dans ce
laboratoire alors essayez vous êtes au
sein du pôle chimie du corps center donc
vous rencontrez surtout des chimistes
qui travaillent soit sur l'assistance
technique à toutes nos filiales soit sur
des projets de recherche et
développement de nouveaux produits
procédés ou méthodes d analyse vous avez
aussi un pôle matériaux qui gère plus
tous les essais sur les produits finis
et vous avez un pôle ingénierie et
dimensionnement qui travaillent sur le
calcul enfin l'auscultation la
modélisation etc est l'une des
innovations que vous développez ici
c'est végécol l'idée c'est de remplacer
le bitume par finalement un enrobé
disons avec de la matière organique
végétal c'est ça oui c'est ça donc
végécol c'est un enrobé clair qui est
fabriqué à partir d'un liant d'origine
végétale donc ce lien il est fabriqué
dans le sud de la france et il est
constitué de résine issus du pain et
d'huile ont obtenu à partir d'oléagineux
comment vous avez travaillé sur ce
projet comment vous l'avez développer
ici
alors c'est un sujet qui a été développé
en transverse donc toutes les tous les
différents acteurs du corps center ont
été mobilisés parce qu'il faut
travailler sur la chimie des matériaux
ensuite il faut les tester en conditions
réelles dans nos produits finis et puis
après il faut ausculté et
évaluer comment se comportent les
produits sur les sites parce que c'est
toujours un peu différent de ce qu'on
voit en laboratoire et donc il faut les
suivre au cours du temps donc on a de
l'auscultation et de la modélisation
pour essayer de comprendre et de
reproduire les phénomènes en laboratoire
et in silico alors comment on fait pour
passer de ça à ça finalement c'est ça on
dit c'est là où j'ai envie de mordre
dedans c'est des barres de céréales
alors c'est un petit peu dur donc je
vous déconseille mais effectivement donc
on va venir travailler à une température
assez modérée on va chauffer l'huile on
va y ajouter de la résine et on obtient
donc ce lien c'est un lien en clair dont
qui permet de mettre en valeur la teinte
naturelle des granulats c'est ce qui
nous permet d'accéder donc à ce type
d'enrobé donc des enrobés clair comme
celui ci ou celui là après vous
choisissez les granulats les cailloux en
fonction de ce que vous voulez obtenir
comme comme esthétique et donc on peut
les utiliser dans des applications type
piste cyclable zone piétonne ou centres
urbains peut circuler est ce qu'on peut
imaginer par exemple remplacer
totalement le bitume par cette solution
mais partout pareil je pense notamment
aux autoroutes où ça c'est ce sera
possible ou alors techniquement ça le
serait le
la seule la seule limitation c'est qu'on
utilise des matières premières à ces
nobles pour faire ce produit pour qu'il
ait ce côté esthétique dont on parlait
et donc c'est quand même dommage de
mettre sur une autoroute où vous allez
avoir des camions qui vont rouler chaque
jour et qui vont laisser des traces
noires sur le sur l'enrobé donc on va
éviter on ira plutôt chercher des
produits justement assez foncée et qui
sont issus des déchets donc des déchets
végétaux pour aller remplacer le bitume
dans ce genre d'application finalement
ce qui change c'est ce qui relie tous
les cailloux finalement c'est ça c'est
ça donc là vous avez la constitution
d'un enrobé donc complètement
éclatée pour bien voir ce qu'il ya
dedans donc vous avez les cailloux de
différentes tailles qui permettent de
constituer l'architecturé la structure
granulaire qui donne le code de la route
et puis vous avez cette partie là qui
est le liant la colle qui permettent
d'assurer la cohésion de l'ensemble des
cailloux entre eux en fait et donc c'est
cette colle là qui est d'habitude du
bitume et qu'on remplace par des
produits issus des végétaux
donc ça c'est le liant chaud c'est sa
septième jour donc c'est ça une fois
qu'il est chaud on obtient cette
consistance de miel qui va permettre de
l'appliquer sur les granulats en faisant
une couche assez fine pour pas que ça
pèse plus d'un mode y est toujours et
papa mais pas trop épaisses justement
pour que
pour qu'on n'ait pas trop non plus sous
soûles et sous les genoux devant la
thématique de la gourmandise quoi du
miel des céréales c'est un peu c'est un
peu de la cuisine dans la chimie en fait
aujourd'hui où est ce qui est du végécol
un range dans le monde dans le monde
même vous en trouvez à dolus d'oléron à
vedène à cuire à magny les hameaux
évidemment on en trouve aussi à la
réunion à rabat au maroc mais on avait
fait ces deux chantiers là quand on
était encore au stade expérimental
pour avoir une idée de la tenue du
produit aux températures élevées enfin
un disque des mines d or merci beaucoup
pour ses explications cette
démonstration aussi je rappelle que vous
êtes chef de projet chimie verte au sein
du groupe colas merci beaucoup derrière
ce calme plaisir et nous on va revenir
sur le salon international de la défense
eurosatory s'est déroulée du 13 au 17
juin dernier parmi les exposants il y
avait thales est thales a présenté son
spider un drone utilisés par l'armée de
terre et qui est développée à elancourt
regarder